[Music]
my name's Shawn get even I work on the
Android Enterprise business team at
Google our team is responsible for the
business to business success of the
Android platform we're a dedicated team
of engineers product managers
go-to-market folks like myself who are
ultimately trying to make sure that
Android is a great platform for your
employees and for business
transformation projects that your
company may want to do and what I wanted
to do is give a little bit of a of a
history of some of the work we've been
doing on the Android platform but more
importantly introduce some marketing
go-to-market initiatives that we've
launched here at Google to hopefully
make understanding how to adopt Android
into your organization easier so you can
focus on real things like what you want
to do inside of your business from a
employee enterprise enablement
perspective we've done a ton of
technical investment in Android going
all the way back to the days of Android
lollipop in Android 5 we introduced this
concept of Android for work and two core
features one which was the idea of the
work profile which helped organizations
who wanted to support BYOD allow
end-users to bring their own devices in
a way that would be secure such that
basically data applications that you
deploy to that end user wouldn't
interact with personal information that
the user may have and more importantly
that was designed to protect user
privacy we wanted to make sure that IT
wasn't snooping on the file system the
photos the music anything else the user
may have brought with them we also in
parallel introduced features for fully
managed devices this was the idea that
if you're kind of thinking about things
in the old blackberry world the idea
that I can lock down the device the idea
that I can whitelist the applications
that go on that device and have a
relatively full degree of control over
the hardware in every version since
Android 5 we've done more technical
investment into the Android platform
we introduced better support for what we
call corporate-owned single-use or
dedicated devices these are the barcode
scanners you see at places like Walmart
offering higher degree of control to
make sure that device is used only for
barcode scanning and not say watching
YouTube on the job we introduced better
support for things like certificates and
carrying on tuna nougat we introduced
improved usability controls like the
work profile challenge so that way if I
go through and allow my nephew to go and
play with my device and I turn off the
work profile so that way my nephew
doesn't play with my email account not
that that would ever happen
there's challenge with the passcode
before before those applications can be
accessed we've introduced features most
recently in Oreo called zero touch this
allows an enterprise to make sure that
as you unbox the device that device
automatically gets enrolled in for
management automatically gets provision
with corporate applications we're really
elevating the experience and activation
process that an end user needs to go
through and now with Android Pi we've
really focused on a lot of those
frontline workers that we've talked
about here at cloud next improving
things like shared device use cases
improving things like support for
multiple users and improving a lot of
the UX around the work profile making it
easier to find the applications that I T
has provisioned out to you to sort of
you know up level a lot of what this
looks like if you haven't adopted
Android Enterprise actually quick show
hands how many folks are actually
running Android inside of your
organization okay I think I can almost
see through the spotlights on the
projector how many of you are running
android enterprise ok only a couple of
you we'll talk about why that's
important in a minute but when you look
at the Android platform and what you're
able to do with it it really allows you
a high degree of flexibility when you
start to go and do things that are more
than just email frankly even if you are
just doing just email the personally
owned world allows it such or makes it
such that IT has very limited control
over what you can do with that device
you can only view and manage the work
applications you have very great little
control
over the device you can provision Wi-Fi
that's about it VPN that's about it and
there's a high degree of separation
between work and personal at a technical
level what we're actually doing is
creating a separate user space on that
device in the person the work profile
world it means that it's almost like
having two instances of Android running
on the same device file systems are
handled separately processes are
isolated memory is isolated even cryptic
cryptographically the data can be stored
different and so it makes sure that
there's a high degree of separation
between work and personal I can't just
click open in and share random data out
to Facebook on the company's own side of
things you can enforce full control over
that device as I mentioned earlier that
could be as simple as white listing what
goes on that device it could be as
complex as creating a full launcher such
that really it almost feels like the
ticket kiosks do you might see here at
the AMC theater I only see those
particular workflows I don't see
anything else on that device and you can
optionally own those fully managed
devices if you're using a corporate
liable as your mechanism of ownership so
you own the device you want to have a
high degree of control most recently
with Android 8 we allow you to deploy a
work profile on those fully managed
devices and what that means is you still
have that high degree of control over
the assets you own but the end user can
go and bring their own apps to work and
there's still that high degree of data
separation between the two so a ton of
flexibility virtually every use case
that we have you know encountered over
the years has been now tackled inside of
the Android Enterprise framework we've
also done a ton of investment into
security we believe that ultimately
Android has to have a high degree of
security and that starts with the
operating system we really you know have
a lot of security tools baked in things
like encryption things like secure boot
so we actually validate that the
operating system has booted properly
we're doing things that integrate the
operating system into the hardware so
when you call cryptographic functions in
Android those keys get stored in a
dedicated secure element on that device
and we also have dedicated
the secure boot process out to that
secure element so it's a high degree of
assurance that that device hasn't been
tampered with before it interacts with
any of the corporate data that you might
decide to put on it we have a lot of
management api's that allow you to
easily customize and tailor and
provision that device experience and we
hook all of this up to Google Play per
tag so Google Play protect how many
folks are familiar with Google pay
protect few people for the rest of you
that aren't familiar with it Google Play
protect is actually what we're doing
here at Google to tackle malware on
Android as well as on on Android VMs in
chrome what we do is we scan every
application that is in Google Play we
are actually using our web search
technologies to go and look out to the
broader web and find applications that
are hosted outside of Google Play and we
scan those as well we can optionally if
the user is opted into this look at the
device itself pull applications off of
it that may have been side loaded and
validate those as well what that means
is every day we're scanning give or take
50 billion different applications to
flag for what what those applications
are and whether they can be paid had
potentially harmful there's always work
to do on this but since we launched this
program it is less likely that you will
die in your bathtub then find malware in
Google Play it used to be that you're
less likely continue with the morbidity
thread that you'd be less likely to get
hit by lightning but we've since
actually broaden our definition of
malware we're hunting for more things
here at Google and in order to create a
safe environment for end users and as we
go and look for more broader sets of
things that are potentially harmful
obviously we're cracking down as well a
lot of the data in that we look at from
a security perspective is also exposed
out to you as developers there's an
entire suite in inside Android called
safety net and that allows you to query
for things like did the device boot
properly has Google Play protect found
malware on this device are my
cryptographic keys still not been
tampered with and so you can actually
have a high degree of certainty
certainly through your management api's
but also you as developers can actually
query for that data to make sure that
the device is in a secure state before
any data is handled
now I like the thing from a Google
perspective we're doing quite well but
it's always better to have validation
from third parties a Gartner has gone
through and done a recent analysis of
various mobile operating systems that
are in the market Android and and others
and what the key thing to look at in
this chart are android eight and then an
android on on pixel which is sort of you
know a very pure version of android and
the key thing also to know in this chart
is that dark blue is better and so in
the gartner zone analysis and there's a
whole video up on youtube that we'll
walk through how this analysis was done
talks to Dave cloud and mark are our VP
of security but the point here is is
that Gartner in this in this objective
analysis found that Android has a higher
degree of security and deeper level of
feature integration from a security
perspective than other platforms in the
market so with the security issue sort
of tackled or certainly an ongoing thing
that we've tackled one question we
wanted to look at at Mobile World
Congress two years ago was how do we
make it easier for you all to procure
devices and more importantly get those
devices under management we know that at
the end of the day business
transformation happens through apps and
we want to make sure that these devices
can be easily unboxed and very easily be
enrolled into whatever mobility
management toolset you're you're using
so you can leverage tools like manage
Google Play and in the last year we've
seen over 50 different resellers join
the Xero touch program these are
resellers that can actually sell you a
device and actually activate it through
Xero touch on 30 of those joined in just
second half of 2018 alone so this is a
program that we continue to expand we
want to be sure that we're working with
the leading resellers that you all rely
on to make sure that you have this great
experience from the Android platform so
with all this with all the things that
we're doing on the platform side of
things and with all the things we're
doing around Xero touch the question we
get from customers is how do I know
what's Enterprise ready I mentioned to
you that back in
five is when we started our
technological investment on Android but
in Android six is where we made it
mandatory
we actually mandated that developers who
were and OMS who were building Android
devices they had to adopt the Android
and a front price framework as a part of
what we call the CD the compatibility
definition document and what that
basically means is devices will come
with Android enterprise as a part of
that framework in fact you can go
through and buy a 50 dollar Android go
device in India unlocked and it will be
enroll about into a mobility management
system like Google Cloud Identity
Manager do I think that that $50 Android
go device is what you should be
deploying to all of your employees
probably not there's a lot of trade-offs
with Android go including around things
like horsepower and memory to get to
that $50 price point in fact the Google
the Android team has built an entire
suite of Go apps that are optimized for
these really low bandwidth low memory
environments and the likelihood that
your enterprise apps like s AP and like
Salesforce will run as well as you would
expect it's probably pretty low so with
so much availability on the Android
platform being out there we really
wanted to answer this question and help
our customers answer this question which
is what can i buy in the market that is
gonna be enterprise class not just
enterprise ready and so we thought about
this from a technical perspective we
really I did and working with our
customers we identified three core areas
that they brought up to us
one was confidence in selection so what
they were asking us was if I buy a
device and I'm particularly a
multinational organization any
multinationals here few of you
so are those devices going to be
available on a worldwide basis can i buy
them unlocked and allow my employee in
london my employee in New York and my
employee in you know Singapore to get
that device and have that device run
inside of my organization the second is
consistency in deployment well we wanted
to make sure was that end users when
they enroll their devices to get access
to corporate data and get access to
applications or having a consistent
experience
now this is not saying that we want to
prevent the OEMs from you know
innovating on top of UX we don't want
the hallways of the world as an example
to stop using their UI frameworks what
we do want to do is make sure that the
enrollment workflows and the settings
workflows to get connected into your
enterprise were largely consistent and
that's what we've been working on with
our OEM partners and finally we wanted
to make sure that devices were current
enough to date we wanted to make sure
that when you buy a device that these
devices were going to get patches at
least once every 90 days and that they
would be getting those patches for a
minimum minimum time period and that
those devices would get at least one
dessert upgrade what we call a dessert
upgrade here at Google is a major
feature update of Android and what that
means is going from as an example
Android ate Oreo to Android nine pie the
desserts are in the names and so those
were the really three criteria that we
saw from customers we then went to the
over 200 OEMs that we worked with and we
asked them who would like to join this
program who is gonna sign up to this
elevated set of criteria and who is
going to go and also commit frankly to
you know things like training making
sure that they understand Android and
they can position at walls of their
customers and since then we've had 12
OEMs bring over 60 different devices to
market that are part of the Android
enterprise recommended portfolio these
devices a lot of the ones I I decided to
throw up here on the slide our flagship
devices just because those are the
shiniest ones that are out there but it
also represents a lot of different price
points you can now go and work with the
likes of Nokia Huawei and LG and find
devices that are at that you know 150 to
300 dollar price point so you can
support things like corporate liable
deployments of androids this is not just
a program targeted at $700 and up from a
flagship perspective it really is every
price point along that graph and so
we're seeing a lot a lot of success I'll
talk about that in a minute of just
customers starting to really think about
this program and using it as a way to
help them procure devices more easily
but we got a bit of a poke which was
that's great for knowledge workers but
what if I'm a Walmart what if I'm using
Android across my entire organization
from the logistics warehouse all the way
out to the storefront those devices you
know as great as the Google pixel 3 is
I've seen you know videos actually did a
really cool case study with Walmart and
material design looking at how those
devices are used in the warehouse the
pixel 3 is probably not gonna go and
hold up to the abuse that a guy who's
trying to you know stack pallets at
Walmart is gonna go and put on it and so
the good news is that you know androids
a very open platform we work with a lot
of different OEMs to build really unique
devices devices that are really built to
suit for a lot of different use cases
and one of those use cases are is the
ruggedized market IDC has as in a few
different research publications
highlighted you know that Android is the
next logical choice for the rugged
market as Microsoft has end-of-life to
the Windows CE II platform and we're
really excited to be working with
leading OEMs like zebra like Honeywell
like Panasonic and sonim Point mobile
Datalogic moto and Motorola Solutions
and Bluebird is really represents the
many of the purpose-built OMS and
ruggedized OEMs in the market and when
we build the criteria for enterprise
recommended for rugged we knew that was
gonna be different than what we should
be thinking about for knowledge workers
we wanted to make sure that enterprise
recommended was you know tackling things
like drop testing tackling things like
dust intrusion and water intrusion in
fact if you go down to the show floor
later today or tomorrow we have many of
these devices up in the android
enterprise recommended area in the
workplace transformation pavilion as you
can get a get a feel for what those
devices look like so what's important to
note here is is that this is not just us
going to the market and saying you know
hey sign up and we'll slap a badge on
we're actually validating that these
devices are meeting these criteria we're
looking at those work workflows for
enrollment and making sure that those
devices are doing the things that are
part of the enterprise recommended
criteria or going through and looking at
how these devices act when they're in
under Enterprise Management
we're not dropped testing devices that
is an area where we look to the partners
to show us validation around things like
IP ratings and the like but we are
actually independently looking at these
devices to ensure they're meeting our
criteria and so far you know we've seen
a lot of really positive reaction from
the market data from hmd global to the
manufacturer of Nokia devices has found
that many or an over 56% folks are aware
of the enterprise recommended program
but more importantly they're really
looking to the program to make
purchasing decisions and data from a
recent survey from in Europe from IDC
said that you know I think as a result
of a lot of the security investment
we've been putting into Android they
believe that those devices that have
been validated by Google and that are
using the latest and greatest for
Android or actually can be more secure
than iOS and we're seeing a variety of
different organizations really looked
toward enterprise recommended as their
way of supporting or the Android
platform inside of their IT organization
HSBC is one of those an HSBC has come
out publicly and stated that they will
only look toward enterprise recommended
devices as they send out requests for
proposals for corporate liable as they
think about their BYOD catalog inside
the bank
you know the notable point also is is
that androids really being proven across
those most sensitive verticals things
places like financial services and and
government and health care and the like
sa P is another partner that has
actually come out very publicly and said
that enterprise recommended was a key
initiative for them and specifically for
BYOD they really a lot of people think
about BYOD
bring your own device and I know I'm not
the recording I am widening my arms a
lot of light as I can but the idea here
is is that you know the challenge with
that is you know can idea sure that
these devices are gonna actually be
secure and be handling corporate data
properly and so many organizations like
sa P and like HSBC when they start their
BYOD programs they really say here are
the catalog of devices we will allow
into our organization BYOD doesn't mean
bring your own everything it means if
you want to support Android here are the
Android devices we were willing to let
in if we don't want to support other
platforms here's the catalog that you
can choose from and we really see a lot
of success from our customers when they
use that method to launch their BYOD
initiatives inside of their company so I
mentioned it's really around these these
three criteria but as we rolled out the
hardware program early last years I
guess think it's almost two years ago
now we heard from our customers that
these were really good initiatives to
helping us figure out hardware but
hardware is not the be-all end-all of a
mobility deployment there's a lot of
cases where there's a dance additional
services additional support additional
software that I might want to roll out
into my organization how do I know that
those are gonna be meeting a similar set
of criteria and will be successful
inside of my mobility deployment and so
this year we launched Android enterprise
recommended services it was really in
response to what we were hearing from
customers around validating the broader
set of ecosystem that android supports
beyond just hardware and we focused on
two core areas one is enterprise
mobility management so the devices are
sorry the suite of services that are
managing devices inside of your
organization as well as managed service
providers so this is the actual partners
the technical partners who may be
offering deployment and support services
to assist your IT departments the EMM
requirements really focused on these
four key areas on the slide but one was
making sure that EMM s were
Epping up to the variety of different
ways that Android can be deployed what
an EMM partner works with Google we
actually do validate the solution sets
whether it's fully managed work profile
corpora dedicated we validate that those
particular software implementations
whether they're in enterprise
recommended or not correspond to the
technical specs that we author but what
we were finding is is that not every EMM
offered every deployment style at the
same time IT was trying to go through
and use Android in a variety of
different deployment scenarios I
mentioned Walmart as an example you can
imagine how you deploy a device at
Walmart or at Marks & Spencer on the
shop floor on the store floor is very
different than how you might deploy
Android inside the accounting department
or the other parts of the carpeted
Enterprise inside of those organizations
and so we really wanted to validate that
advanced feature sets from at least two
of the different deployment mechanisms
of Android Enterprise two of the three
were supported we wanted to make sure
also that these partners were offering
dedicated technical leadership I
actually came from MobileIron
before I joined Google in many cases EMS
act as the frontline of support for many
mobility deployments because it's the
sort of the glue that's holding things
together and actually activating the
deployment of devices inside of
corporate IT and so we wanted to make
sure that these organizations did two
things one was that in managing Android
and a prior Android Enterprise would be
the default and primary mode of
management that these pieces of software
would be using inside of deployments and
two that there was guidance and
documentation for customers that were
either rolling out or migrating to
Android Enterprise we really wanted to
make sure that best practices from
Google were well established not just
from ourselves but from these technical
partners that are going out and helping
customers deploy Android inside of their
enterprise we wanted to make sure that
they were offering enterprise level
support so we were actually been doing a
lot of training from Google of these
to make sure that if you call a given
EMM they understand at least their
escalation teams while understand the
Android platform they can troubleshoot
how Android is deployed inside of an
organization and finally we really
wanted to make sure there was a proven
ability to put to deploy that these
particular partners had worked with
large IT organizations had demonstrable
success with these IT organizations and
frankly made sure that their fields
field organisations their sales and
technical sales specialists were well
trained by Google about Android
enterprise so that the relevant
technical knowledge was being conveyed
to the customer we're really excited by
this
traction we're getting in the early days
of enterprise recommended we've had so
far nine partners join this program many
of these are the ones that are in the
top right of various market surveys
whether they be from Forrester Gartner
or IDC and you know we really are
pleased with the level of technical
leadership that they're bringing to DT
technical leadership they're bringing to
the table in support of your your
enterprise mobility deployments the
second area was around managed service
providers there's a lot of organizations
particularly if you look in the desktop
world that have decided to outsource
frontline support or outsource the
deployment services for platforms like
Windows Mac and you know even Chromebook
and so we wanted to make sure as
organizations start to look toward their
mobility deployments being handled in
the same way that managed services
providers were really really well
trained and offered a high degree of
technical depth in supporting your
deployments so again you know really
falls in these three core areas of
confidence and selection that these
folks are validated and trained by
Google that they have proven expertise
that they have consistent training and
standardized on escalation processes
from Google and that they're always
contained current on the latest training
requirements and frankly that they
routinely collaborate us on with us on
business objectives Android is obviously
an ever-evolving platform and so we
don't want to make sure that our partner
is both the EMS as well as the EMA
peas are continually keeping up to date
and the services that they're bringing
to the market from a deeper dive into
where that platform looks like we
mandate that 80% of the sales and
technical sales specialists are trained
in what we call Android Academy so
Android Academy is a plot as a program
we launched about 18 months ago designed
to make sure that the best practices and
knowledge of Google is out there in the
market for those of you that are curious
it's up at Android Enterprise training
and that is designed to target toward
two core areas one is sales specialists
that you understand how to base do basic
positioning of the Android platform you
know you understand how you know that
Android is secure and that it can be
used to do really cool things around
business transformation and then it
dives into a higher degree of technical
depth for technical sales specialists
not just that Android is secure but that
Android actually how Android offers that
security how that security is integrated
of the hardware so you can position that
data to your customer we've since
expanded that program through an
invite-only program called the Android
Enterprise expert's program and that
really takes a much deeper set of
validation to the individual we're
actually going through and what we'll
show you in a minute that well show you
now we actually are taking folks into
the lab and we're making sure they know
that how to troubleshoot something if
something goes wrong we introduce
failure scenarios an extra that we've
seen from actual deployments and make
sure that the support and deployment
engineers know how to troubleshoot to
these particular processes and these MSP
trainings were run by Google these were
our partner and customer engineering
teams from Mountain View New York and
London that traveled around the world to
train all of these individuals and so we
went when we launched the program
mandated that the partners have at least
two Android enterprise experts and two
Android support engineers in each region
that they serve we also mandated that
these
folks be trained on EMS and that they
actually be trained and I think you
believe at least two EMM and finally
that they have demonstrated
demonstrative technical ability through
customer deployments and deploying
Android Enterprise since we launched the
program we've had a variety of some of
the leading organizations in enterprise
mobility services step up to the plate
and join this program leading brands
like Accenture and cognizant and DXE a
TAC on a common Honeywell I have have PO
need up the technical resources needed
to ensure that they are offering great
services to the market and I've been in
mobility for quite some time I've very
rarely seen engineers get nervous in
training programs but the Android the
the Android experts program was one of
those where folks were definitely put to
the test and we're super excited to have
these partners joining us so you know we
took it this from a holistic level the
we've really been investing on a program
by program basis to make sure that all
of the different partners that you work
with are well served by the best
knowledge of from Google the best serve
ala Dacian of the services that these
folks provide that the software we
provide is being corporated into these
product suites and that this this
evolved over time with every release of
Android we're continuing to evolve the
technical requirements for devices the
training requirements for EMS and MSPs
and so you this will be an evolving
program but where you'll see hopefully
new partners I joined the program but
certainly also there's an assurance that
these partners are validated as new
versions of Android come out I'll leave
you with this I asked at the beginning
of this presentation how many folks were
running Android and lots of different
hands went up and then I asked how many
of you were running Android Enterprise
and not as many hands monopoly a few for
those of you that are running Android
inside of your organization
many of you may have been using legacy
software to do it
there was a suite of tools we offered
priority Android 5 called device
administrator it offered basic
client-side api's to set a device
passcode to turn off hardware like
Bluetooth or the camera and these were
really basic tools almost like the very
basic suite of policies that came with
active sync and the early days of
Windows Mobile we've since deprecated a
lot of those client-side api's in
android 9 we actually deprecated
passcode and device hardware controls in
documentation so if you call those api's
on android 9 you'll get an error saying
this isn't supported anymore and Android
10 we're actually going to turn those
API is off so if your organization is
looking to actually support Android
Enterprise a support Android from IT
management perspective it's really
important that you be looking to the
Android enterprise framework to actually
roll this out in your organization up on
our blog at blog Google in the Android
Enterprise product update section we
have an entire there's a blog post and a
blue book that we've launched to help
you understand how to tackle that
migration to take a cap and grow
strategy to your Android deployment to
make sure that the latest devices in
rolling can actually work in the enjoyed
Enterprise framework and certainly from
our perspective we're making sure that
our EMM our mobility management partners
and our services partners are
well-trained to help you through that
journey
[Music]